hello my name is Barbara orlofsky we are
here together with president of markup
and Asian Tamar Sadowski we are social
entrepreneurs we establish market 22
years ago in Poland and we focus on
development of human capital development
of people who are out of the market out
of the society because of Communists
because law education because of lack of
entrepreneurial skills and we are here
because we we think that our experiences
our models can be useful all over the
Europe and also in Asia we could share
along with the model how to how to
develop people who are very poor who
could start in life but they don't see
any perspectives so social enterprises
are very strong movement in Poland now
they are rooted in local communities
local environment they are rooted in
solidarity approach and to local
awareness that everybody can be
productive can be in better in the
situation and we look for partners and
we think that we could we can add
something innovative to these meetings
and sessions we would like to add that
not only material capital is important
not only infrastructures not only
natural resources but also we can we can
prepare institutions which can which can
develop those who are now better than
who are burden for the society and they
can be productive they can fill a play
or control 24 general Welles and general
development of the countries thank you